PHYSICAL ONE.OT
DEFLECTED AWAY. FROM THE
DEFENSIVE ZONE.
WATCH THE WAY EHLERS PUTS THEE Y
IN THE GAME.
ACROSS THE ICE BY MORRISSEY.
BOUNCES in: WHAT MAKES THIS TOP
LINE FROM DUBOIS, CONNOR, AND
EHLERS WORK?
CROSS-ICE.
TRADE DEADLINE ON MONDAY.ERE,
AND OUT.M IS SOMETHING THE
ANOTHER SHOT, HELLEBUYCK GOT THE
IT BACK INSIDE THE YS IT BACK,
TONINATO BACK TO THE LINE.
AND BRENDEN DILLON HAD TO BE
CAREFUL WITH THAT BUT THEF
DE,
TO THE INSIDE, COULDN'T GET A
SHOT  EN ROUTE, THAT  WRAPAROUN
CONNOR HELLEBUYCK MAKES THE SAVE
ON THE SHORT SIDE AS THE EFFORT
FOLIGNO DRIVES IT IN ONCORRECT,
GOING TO THE NET, DOESN'T MAKE
AN ATEMPERATURE. BACKY AND THATA
STICK AND UPY SCHMIDT.R THE JET.
>> Kevin: YEAH, AND IT STARTS
WITH WHEELER JUST RUMBLING
CONNOR TRACKS IT DOWN.NE, ITS W
CONNOR WITH SOME ROOM.
CROSS-ICE,
FAVOURING BOSTON HERE IN THE
SEC.
SHOT THE BOSTON
ZONE.
SVECHNIKOV WILL LEAVE IT.
CONNOR TRI TO
THE LINE FOR NATE SCHMIDT AND HE
GOT TRWHILE.
BACK WITH ADAM LOWRY.
THE TOE DRAG, GOOD SKILL, YOU
HAVE
ARLZ THROUGH CENTRE FOR KYL PLA.
THE JETS HAVE THE START OF THE
BACK TO STANLEY.OUNTER
THROUGH THE MIDDLE, WHEELER HITS
THE LINE.
WHEELER, SCHEIFELE, SCHEIF
ROOM.
INTO THE BOSTON ZONE.
>> Kevin: SEE HOW BEING LIKE TH.
MORRISSEY IS
IT,
PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS ON THE LOOSE
PUCK.
MORRISSEY MAKES THIS POWER PLAYR
BOSTON.
THROUGH TRAFFIC, BLOCKED IN  TH
McAVOY ON FOR COYLE.
AND INTO THELD HAVE BEEN A
PENALTY, A TRIPPING CALL.